bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono bravi gerico ragazzi sto
preparando un blog speciale per questo
sabato deciso di fare un episodio
particolare questa settimana qui ho
visto che impazzata in rete
l'applicazione è quella che ti cambia la
faccia che avevo già fatto tra l'altro
però visto che ne è uscita una nuova
gara la mia gioia soprattutto si chiama
masquerade che sarebbe questa qui che
non ho preso a sbattere le palpebre ma
che è possibile come fanno applicazioni
così ad avere tanti scaricamenti tipo
e vabbè riesco a intra farmi entrare la
mano e un casco tarocco nara di chiudere
shulman dentro ecco per me cazzo lo
chiudo amica scat è un po arrugginito
che mi ascheri capelli a quei servizi
sul web per il classico e diversamente
la notte volta ragazzi questa volta ciò
anche il partner che sarebbe buzz
lightyear fermi il secondo ragazzi che
non so se mi riconosce la faccia di buzz
lightyear oddio o mio dio sono buzz
lightyear tutto e figlia da quando ho
provato sta cosa difesa per questo è
stata la cosa più [ __ ] in assoluto
bellissimo lo faccio per i cosmetici
andiamo avanti che lo smog uil e guide
pulito e non avverrà che è bellissimo ci
non ho mai proprio della madonna tutto
sporco ficcato nella testa nel camino
mi chiamo di geri martin garics che
cazzo di maniglie
[Musica]
hermione vuoi vederla la mia bacchetta
il boccino ma domani a melo ma veramente
dove fai anche tu le caramelle boccino
sapore la mia lingua a sono sott'acqua
ma come cazzo faccio a parlare spiega
[Musica]
allora non ce la posso fare con pasta
letti arriva scassa darei a farlo
provare con harry potter buzz lightyear
orecchie a questo figo
minchia sono borat aspettarmi devo
provarlo con borat ragazzi scusate mi è
più fa eco mi chiamate perche i baffi
per la prima volta la mia vita passata
bella patata bere ma basta angolo perciò
che cazzo di motivo sai di me 3b dei
kiwi dean che cosa chi min
perché dovrei farmi una foto così spiega
ma neanche d'accordo ma odio david bowie
oddio bellissimo amica queste fatto
veramente bene i'm not fair josè limon
ma chiozza a sé ma perché io mi sono
montato la testa qui non voglio che sia
riconosciuto e allora vado in giro così
che sono comunque più bello di prima per
carità bellissimo allora ho visto che su
snap shot hanno sbloccato un sacco di
roba tipo che sta roba
peccato
perché cazzo se batman su snapshots
donne volete vedere il mio pipistrello
tornei quanto può essere raccapricciante
ed effetto
[Musica]
cosa vado via via mia faccia
la madonna porca [ __ ] aspetta vuole
provare batman su buzz lightyear primi
tutti ragazzi buzz lightyear e la star
indiscussa di questo video ci
mancherebbe melo date un naso che io non
lo trovo fatti vedere basse
eccolo lì il mio uomo veramente stati 20
madonna ragazzi questo veramente
orribile bastardo o questo e questo è
per te basta questo per te verso
l'infinito con gli occhiali vannoni
questo sei tu
veramente qualche altra no vabbè datemi
un qualcosa dove metto la firma e mi
lasciano così vi prego parlante è finita
sarebbe un problema da spiegare a mia
madre ma non a minimi limone rei da solo
design astronomia ave che sarà ho già
vista bella vero apra la bocca mica
quante formale quando vedi una bella
[ __ ] in giro è la stessa cosa cioè un
facebook che devo assolutamente farmi
che devo provare a vedere se funziona
ciò la barba ragazzi cioè che i bar ma
attenzione allo ragazzi dire che posso
concludere qui ho capito perché
impazzata un questa mania sta diventando
una roba o proprio sosta vasta
applicazione concludo che l'episodio
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto scorsi in seguito è piaciuta su
argomento è un mi piace anche a pagina
di facebook come video totale iscrizione
se non si discute ci vediamo al prossimo
video belle ragazze